but it's also been an opportunity to
start to talk to leaders about how we
can reform the EU and the UK's
relationship with it
Britain benefits from having access to
the world's largest single market and as
a member of the EU we can get things
done on issues that we care about a
greener environment tackling poverty
standing up for democracy and the values
that we cherish but we need to address
the concerns of the British people they
are not happy with the status quo and
frankly neither am i there's the concern
that we're being driven towards an ever
closer Union that may be what some
others want but is not for us there's
the unnecessary and burdensome EU rules
that hold some of our businesses back
and stop them from seizing the enormous
potential of the single market and
there's the concern of course but I
fully share about a huge increase in
people migrating to the UK from Europe
and the fear that we can do nothing to
address this now I believe we can find a
way through all of these problems I
believe we can transform our
relationship with Europe for the better
and that is what I've now embarked upon
today I held discussions with Donald
Tusk the president of the European
Council and leaders from Poland Sweden
Hungary and Latvia next week I'll meet
with President Hollande and Chancellor
Merkel our whole talks with the
president of the European Commission and
I'll be visiting other European capitals
too I don't expect to find agreed
solutions straight away as I said this
morning these talks will require
patience and tenacity there'll be a lot
of ups and downs along the way but by
working together in the right spirit and
sticking at it I believe we can reform
the EU and our relationship with it and
then the British people will have the
final say in an in-out referendum they
will decide but I want to give them a
proper choice staying in a reformed
European Union or leaving and that's why
these negotiations these talks which
really just started to scratch the
surface with today are so important